e
e e
be up here in front of everybody so join
in with us please as we sing and we're
going to get started um I believe
Michael's going to lead this first
song you want to count us off chlo
[Music]
when darkness tries to roll over my
bones when sorrow comes to steal the joy
I when when Brokenness and pain is all I
know but I Won't Be
Shaken I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your love
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your
[Music]
love shame no longer has a place to
hide and I am not a captive to the
lies I'm not afraid to leave my past
behind I Won't Be
Shaken I won't be Shen
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love my fear doesn't stand
a chance when I stand in your love my
fear doesn't stand a chance when I stand
In Your
[Music]
Love there power that can break off
every chain
this power that could empty out
grave this resurrection power that is
save this power in your name power in
your
name this power that can break off every
chain this power that could empty out
Gra
this resurrection power that
is this power in your name power in your
name my feet doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your love
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your
love your
love stand it in your
love you're
love standing Your
[Music]
Love All right well kiddos that's your
cue that you are dismissed to go line up
at the doors and your teachers will walk
you to your classrooms from there so if
y'all will wait for them to lead you out
of here we'll make sure you get safely
to where you need to go and while
they're making their way out in here
we're going to go ahead and transition
into what we participate in each week
called prayers of the people and it is
an age-old practice that um the church
has taken part in for years but it's
something where we like to take time in
our service to not only make space to
pray for the world and those around us
but to off also offer up any of our own
things that we carry into this space so
Eve's going to lead us in the prayers of
the people and if you guys on the screen
any of the red Parts if you will um go
ahead and say that aloud with her as she
leads
us for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for The Good
Earth you have given us and the will and
the wisdom to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to
you for the poor the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or per other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
amen worthy of every song we could ever
sing worthy of all the praise we could
ever bring
worthy of every bre we could ever bring
we live for
you oh we live for
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could ever
save
worthy of every breath we could have a
breathe we live for you oh we live for
you
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you you are and
fill me with your heart and Lead Me In
Your Love to those around
[Music]
me worthy of every song we could ever
sing
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring worthy of every breath we could
ever breathe we live for you oh we live
for
[Music]
you Jesus the only of every other name
Jesus the only one who could ever
save worthy of every breath we could
ever breathe we live for you oh we live
for
you
holy there is no one like you there is n
beside you open up my eyes and
wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love to those around
me I will build my life
upon your love it is a
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone and I will not be
Shen I will build my life upon your
love is a firm foundation
I will put my trust in you
alone and I will not be
Shen
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are in F me
with your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
to
those around me
[Music]
my life upon your love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone and I will not
be
[Music]
Shen Christ is my
Foundation The Rock on reaches stand
when everything around be
shaken I never been more glad that I put
my faith in
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful through
generations so why would he feel now he
will
he
W I still got joy in
chaos I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be going
under not help I'm My Own Strength I
built my life on Jesus
[Music]
he's never let me down he's faithful in
every
season so why would he fail
now he
won
he he won't
fa he won't fail
he
won he
won he won't
fail he won't
[Music]
rain came wind blew my house was built
on
you I'm safe with you
I'm going to make it
through
came my house my spirit all
you I'm
safe you I'm going to make
[Music]
it
came my house was buil on
I'm safe with you I'm going to make
it I'm going to make it
through I'm standing strong on
you I'm going to make it
through my house was built on
through I'm standing
strong
you I'm going to make you
through my house was built on
you oh
has his my thir
Foundation The Rock on which I stand
when everything around me
Shen I'm never been more glad I put my
faith in
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he fa now
he he
W he won't
F he won't
fa
he he
oh he won't
fail he won
fail he
[Music]
will I build my life on
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he feel now he
[Music]
will God I just give this time to
you and I think of
um you as our Firm Foundation as this
immovable
constant steady ground that we stand on
and it reminds me of the scriptures um
where it talks about the Earth giving
way and the mountains May quake and
everything fall into the sea and yet you
are steady and steadfast and
firm so God I do pray that we would
build our lives on
you and that you would be a rock when
all else else fails when all else is
shaken and we turn to you and give you
our attention we give you our hearts
right now in Jesus name
amen if you guys want to turn to your
neighbors and just say hello or if you
see someone that you don't recognize
especially say hi introduce yourself ask
their name
oh Grace and
peace my name is
Brett some of you don't know that
because I've been the absentee pastor
but but uh I'm back now uh and really
really glad to be with you all to um
just to welcome you into this space and
as always that includes those joining us
online love you a lot and um anyone here
tonight who is new thank you for for
being Among Us it's a it's a big deal
and I know it can take a lot of courage
to walk through those doors come into a
new space new community and uh yeah can
just be a lot so just know um yeah we
really you're here and Hope hope you
find a just a a god of compassion a
Christ of Love community of Welcome uh
here at the table so
um yeah this is my first Sunday back
after a little a little mini is that
what you call Mini sabatical it's like
longer than a vacation because it was a
month you know so longer than vacation
maybe less than like a full-blown
sabatical and um just part of our rest
rhythms here at the table we usually
take some down time um in July and so um
I do every year my wife Maggie for the
first time joined me and that was that
was great and um yeah we really did we
had just a wonderful a wonderful break
there is something I think um maybe I
don't know if all jobs like this
certainly pastoring can become like a
kind of an identity thing you know where
it's like you just become the role and I
think that's where extended breaks like
that are really um really important
because it just it kind of I don't know
it breaks that like suddenly you're just
you know at least for my or in my case
just I'm just Brett you know not Pastor
bread and oh you know just uh just Brett
and that's another something really
beautiful about that um so we did have a
great time away I read many good books
we went on the most epic of all family
vacations to Hawaii I know right right I
mean that's pretty that's pretty epic it
really it was it was beautiful um and
I'll tell a story about that later um
but yeah it really was it was great
great time and I also want to give a
huge thank you to I don't won't mention
Everyone by name but just all the folks
who spoke while I was out we had a
number of guest speakers that amazing
and we had folks leading in worship and
there's just all sorts of roles that as
you know we step out other step up so if
that was you thank you I'm so so
grateful um so we're kicking off a uh a
new series tonight titled The Parables
of Jesus and uh what is a parable you
ask I'm so glad you asked so uh Jesus
was really known for these these short
stories um many of them are quite kind
of Punchy and and like real real
powerful um and this method it seems to
be fairly unique to Jesus in the sense
like we we don't really know of like a
larger tradition you know a tradition of
the parable and this style of
Storytelling that he's like drawing on
in Jewish tradition or you it's not like
oh you find Parables just all throughout
the Bible the prophets love to tell
Parables like not not really uh these
these these stories they seem to have
just kind of bubbled up from the depths
of Christ's own being which I I think
you know is kind of a sign like hey if
we're going to follow Jesus we're going
to be followers of Christ it make a lot
of to pay close attention right to these
stories that he's he's telling so
through the series we'll be going
through um a number um of these
summarizing what parables are all about
I love this quote from Christian
Theologian Ron Williams he writes these
are not religious stories or expositions
of a tradition but rather
crystallizations of how people decide
for or against
self-destruction or against newness of
Life
acceptance
relatedness it's a it's a Prof found in
other words these aren't cutesy
religious stories that are kind of like
adorable you know like oh yeah these
little Parables these cute little
stories of Jesus you know I learned
about him in Sunday school or whatever
like these if you really reflect on them
um like these are about our life at its
depths in its roots like it's it's
asking questions like what are you
pointed towards what type of person are
you you
becoming like that's not a cutesy little
religious you know what I mean that's
like a hard-hitting like I need to think
about this so so that's that's kind of
the the weightiness of these um of these
Parables so our first one tonight and
the title of my message is the parable
of the swer it's a famous One Matthew 13
1-9 and then kind of cool it's one of
those where um he gives the
interpretation so then we'll skip down
and we'll read verses 18- 23 so um let
me let me read this to you that same day
Jesus went out of the house and sat by
the lake such large crowds gathered
around him that he got into a boat and
sat in it while all the people stood on
the shore this by the way was a common
way Jesus taught partly because it's
like a natural
Amphitheater right so you think of a way
water and such carries sound have you
ever had that weird experience where
someone's talking on water and like you
can weirdly hear them from an odd
distance you know on land you could
never hear them so they would often use
he would use water and such like that to
um to teach so okay so there he's stood
on the shore then he told them many
things in Parables saying a farmer went
out to sew his seed as he was scattering
the seed some fell along the path and
the birds came and ate it up some fell
on Rocky places where it did not have
much soil it sprang up quickly because
the soil was shallow but when the sun
came up the plants were scorched they
withered because they had no root other
seed fell among Thorns which grew up and
choked the plants still other seed fell
on good soil Where It produced a crop
160 or even 30 times what was sown
Whoever has ears let them hear and we
skip down to verse 18 this is where he
gives the interpretation because this
you know on the surface it sounds like
oh it's a farming Parable that's cool um
but it's of course not really about
farming or something listen then to what
the parable of the sewer means when
anyone hears the message about the
kingdom and does not understand it the
evil one comes and snatches away what
was sown in their heart this is the seed
sewn along the path the seed falling on
Rocky ground refers to someone who hears
the word and at once receives it with
joy but since they have no root
they last only a short
time when trouble or persecution comes
because of the word they quickly Fall
Away the seed falling among the Thorns
refers to someone who hears the word but
the worries of this life in the
deceitfulness of wealth choke the word
making it unfruitful but the seed
falling on good soil refers to someone
who hears the word and understands it
this is the one who produces a crop
yielding 160 or 30 times what was
sewn so that's the story and the the
main
question uh driving my message tonight
is um is this what does it mean to be
good
soil you can tell in the in the parable
um right the question of soil seems to
kind of lie at the very um heart of what
what this whole thing is about right
because in each instance you have the
same SE right or or planter the one say
sewer because back right in our day we
think of planting a seed like you know
you put it in the ground like gardening
or something you know you dig a little
hole and put in there back in the day
they had you know lots of seed so they
would just grab someone had like a bag
they would gather they just kind of
throw it you just kind of sew it like
just right so in the story you have the
same sewer
uh Christ right and you have the same
seed which is something like the this
word of the Kingdom this this good news
of a life with God a life I mean it's
all the things we were singing about
earlier you know Christ is my Foundation
the The Rock on which I stand the you
the the sense of centeredness and
groundedness and rootedness in God
you're not just bullied by life right
some something along those lines so in
each instance you have same sewer same
seed but very different outcomes each
time right based on what well if you
read the story uh you could say it was
based on certain external circumstances
you know for example um there's um verse
19 the evil one comes and snatches it
away you know kind of represented by the
birds
um or later in uh verse 20 it's because
it lacks Roots right and the third it's
choked out by the Thorns of worry and
this kind of culture of a grasping sort
of greed so right in essence you could
read the parable and say oh no no it's
about it's about that stuff right you
could say it's a the devil it's the the
devil did it you know or something or uh
it's this culture's fault can you you
believe this culture we're in it's so
consumeristic and and greedy and you
know I mean like you could it's that
that's why like I would be all in you
know except for these things it's like
they're messing you know they're messing
me up um but the emphasis of the parable
it doesn't really seem to be there it
mentions these things but it that
doesn't seem to be the main point
instead Jesus seems to be um emphasizing
the soil itself
self and right in because in the first
instance it says it's the seed is sewn
along a path what's a path like is that
like soft fertile soil of course not you
know obviously the feet pack it down so
especially if you get that image again
not of gardening and like digging but of
someone throwing some seed on a path
it's just what's happening it's going to
lay there on top and then of course as
the parable goes just to be eaten by
some animal or birds or something right
um or you think in the second instance
it says the soil's thin it's it's Rocky
right or in the third it's the soil is
actually quite good but it's it's filled
with thorns and brambles and other um uh
kind of vegetation that chokes right
chokes it out so um right over and over
and over again in the parable it's it's
the soil it's the soil it's it's these
types of soil and that's I think that's
kind of what Jesus is kind of pushing us
to to be reflecting on okay so it's a
parable about many things but you could
say at least one of the big things about
is about the soil so what
exactly is the
soil does that make sense that's that's
the question right it's like okay so in
other words if like oh the swer is
Christ and the seed is the word of the
Kingdom this life be rooted in God and
Union with God or something to that
effect and the birds are the evil one
and the the Thorns are the the you know
the the the greed of this world and the
broader culture and so you know like
okay everything's symbolic everything
kind has this thing and the soil
is you know yes
us and and I'm kind of where my mind's
going is and what's specifically within
us you know like in essence what what
aspect of our life or what part of our
being or what like what what's it what's
this what's this about and um you know
based on certain kind of key words in
the in the story I think we might be
tempted to
say it's it's the it's like our
rational linear thinking like mind like
it's our it's our brain um because
there's this word that shows up over and
over it's um or a few times there you
see it in um verse 23 says but the seed
falling on good soil refers to someone
who hears the word and understands it
right so there's like this kind of you
know oh okay okay the soil it's like
understanding like if you got to get it
you know but if you don't get it well
then you know you're you're like bad
soil um
so you could you could go that direction
you could say ah the soil it's like this
intelligent mind and so you know the
smarter and more educated you are the
quicker on the uptake you are the better
soil you are you know but if you're like
I'm real slow on stuff you know just not
it's not firing I don't get it you know
Theology and all that I'm just kind of I
don't know well then uhoh you got to you
know up your game because you're not you
know you're not good that's so
um and I do think certain wings of the
Christian tradition have if not maybe
quite that extreme have hinted at
something along those lines have kind of
here the um you can kind of see in the
way churches will do like evangelism
which means you know like spreading the
word and sharing with others about Jesus
and the way they do discipleship meaning
training people up it really kind of
becomes very information heavy right in
essence it's about getting the proper
information
into people's brains so they that key
word they understand it they understand
it right it's like if they'll understand
well then once they understand they can
believe um and which by the way I think
the word understand is in the parable so
I'm not saying like it has nothing to do
with that no I think there's some
there's something to be said for you
know understanding and thinking stuff
through and um but there's also some
other words that I think kind of hint
maybe at a a broader
context here that um we should be
considering so um and I say that because
I think there's I think we all know
there's kind of a difference between
understanding a thing like
intellectually like breaking it down and
explaining it back like I get it I get
that there's like that kind of knowing
or understanding and then there's that
other kind isn't there there's that kind
where it like sinks into your bone B and
like
experientially you're like no no I get
it you know what I mean like there's I
get it I read that in a book yep I could
I could tell you about that you mean
there's like that knowing and then
there's no
no I get it you know I mean there's that
that kind of deeper uh deeper deeper
knowing a kind of understanding that
sinks in and transfigures us and there's
another word introduc early in the
interpretive portion of the parable that
indicates that something deeper going on
it's found in verse 19 our context will
start in verse 18 listen then to what
the parable of the s means when anyone
hears the message about the kingdom and
does not understand it there's that word
again the evil one comes and snatches
away what was sown in their
what
heart what was swn in their heart this
is the seed swn along the path so you've
got the word understanding there again
but you've also got this kind of broader
context for understanding which where
Jesus uses this word um this word
heart we right in in essence what
determines whether one understands in
the deepest
sense it's not just well I'm smart you
know I mean I oh I've really read I've
read a lot of theology I've really I've
studied you know uh um
you you can do that but if the
heart isn't in a good
place it's all
just
nothing it's all just
abstractions AB by abstractions I mean
it's sort of not rooted in actual life
you know I mean it's just
information ideas and information know
it's just uh as the the people online
say content God I hate that word but
just you know just content just content
it's content you want content I can give
you content content I'll give you
Christian content you want Christian
content well just you know and it's
becomes a sort of there's just a
difference though between like yes I get
you know and this deeper um kind of
settled deeper knowing and and what is
that it's about the state of one's heart
in fact if you look at the exact same
parable
um in Luke so we've been um in uh this
other right kind of gospel if you go
over to Luke 8:14 same Parable slightly
different language it puts it this way
the seed that fell among Thorns stands
for those who hear but as they go on
their way they are choked by life's
worries riches and pleasures and they do
not mature but the seed on good soil
stands for those with a noble and good
what heart who he hear the word retain
it and by persevering produce a crop
right the soil is the heart this Parable
is is about the heart and this of course
this resonates as a major theme across
scripture I think of like 1st Samuel
16:7 people look at the outward
appearance don't they people do look at
the outward appearance that's you know
people look at the outward appearance
where does the Lord look
right to the
heart or here's the Book of Proverbs
Above All Else guard your heart
everything you do that which is quite a
statement everything you
do
everything that's a that's big not like
50% that would still be a lot even if it
said 50% I'd be like wow this is worth
paying attention to you know but is 100%
everything we do flows from that
flows from the heart or Christ himself
Matthew 5'8 blessed are the pure in
heart for they will see
God but maybe this just pushes the
problem back further you know we say aha
okay so it's a parable about soil and
the soils about the
heart and the Heart
Is you know it's like is there you
talking about like the the thing in my
chest like beating right now you know
hopefully um you know it's like that the
the heart the
um what is this getting at what what is
this uh what is this this heart I think
it's a a little bit hard to articulate
in words right this is I would say kind
of metaphorical or poetic language it's
it's pointing to something um as we
named earlier within it's us it's
something within us um but but what
exactly is it I think we might we might
say it like this a good heart so to
speak is a still quiet open
non-judgmental non
reactionary state of
mind I think that's what the heart
is a still quiet open non-judgmental non
reactionary state of mind I say we we
know this more by
experience this is where I say words are
a little tricky here you kind of have to
know you ever been in that place where
you're just in a good
place on the inside you know mean I
don't mean out where in the world I mean
like you are good you know there's this
settledness kind of an
openness certain peace certain quiet
here I think this is some of why the
biblical writers use the language of
heart um because there's a kind of
dropping down sens ation right if you're
maybe struggling to follow me you're
like I don't know if I've ever been like
that well you've certainly been the
opposite uh anyone familiar with that in
the uh words of Daddy Pig from Peppa Pig
uh I'm a bit of an expert at that you
know I think we're all a bit of an
expert at that right there's the other
mind which is furious
judgmental reactionary freaking afraid
all the time panicky you know they're
there's certain like if anyone familiar
with that right at the very least we're
familiar with that mind you know that
state of
being and
um and then it's then there's the
opposite and I think we all know like
man when we're in that place that kind
of reactionary freaking out you know
when we're in that place we aren't well
and as the Book of Proverbs says it
impacts everything we do doesn't it I
mean every word every gesture I mean
it's weird how people can even kind of
read your heart so to speak you know I
mean the state of of deep mind you know
by like they just pick up on you know I
mean it's just we're we're emanating it
you know um and vice versa like I know
I'm like oh I love when I can parent or
be a good partner to Maggie or Pastor 3
PS I'm a preacher parent partner Pastor
was pretty good okay right I love like
when I can be all those and do that from
that kind of
openhearted non-judgmental non
reactionary unafraid kind of place like
when I'm in that place it's just like oh
my gosh everything flows you know and
then of
course there's the other way of being um
which we're all myself included pulled
into all the time and that's what Jesus
is saying ah not good
soil not good
soil there's a few quotes Martin La
who's a modern Theologian um I highly
recommend his book I read it over the
break into the silent land into the
silent Land by wonderful he says this
the key is to move from being a victim
of thoughts the commenting chattering
mind to being their
witness the heart's Stillness that's it
like that that I think in essence is my
interpretation which I am interpreting
just to be clear you know I mean I
totally get how other pastors could
stand up here and give you a slightly
different emphasis different you know
what I mean reading so just my reading
um I think it's a beautiful reading I
think it's a
great um reading what L's getting at
here moving from this being a victim of
thoughts the commenting chattering mind
right to the heart Stillness that's why
I say these biblical writers and early
Christian writers they love this
language of the heart I think because as
this quiets
down you get the sense it's not that
you're not thinking anymore right so
technically it is still the mind but
it's you do get this sensation of living
from deeper right you get this sense of
living more from
where right more from the core that's
why I think they use the language of the
heart the core live from the actually
there's another quote that gets right at
this St theopen the recluse great that's
a great title um he says this get out of
the
mind and into what heart now might be a
little confusing because I just said the
heart is the mind you know and you're
like what is you talking about well I
think what he's saying is get out of
that mind you know that mind we were
talking about earlier and anxiety mind
the Freak Out mind the J right get out
of that mind and get into the heart the
heart Stillness the the witness the
quiet settled rooted in God kind of
place um as I mentioned earlier we took
a trip to paradise I'll close the story
um Paradise you would think if there's
anywhere you could
escape the hell of the mind you know it
would be paradise you know but uh I mean
we had a great time but NOP no no the
Mind goes with you you know and honestly
it was lots went good we had but there
was challenges along the way but overall
it was a beautiful trip but we had um
quite an experience coming home I I got
permission to share this story with my
kids so
um we it were we wanted the cheap flight
you know affordable um so we're leaving
at 10:30 Hawaii time and um 10:30 p.m.
yeah so we're going to fly through the
night and we're like walking onto the
plane and one of our kids
says I don't feel so good if it were a
movie that would be like the framing
shot I mean there it's for it's called
foreshadowing you know I mean it's sort
of a hint of what is to come you know I
don't feel so good and sure
enough baby this PO kiddo they um they
threw I think our last count was 16
times between
the flight five hours from Hawaii to Los
Angeles three hours from Los Angeles to
Dallas 16th we had 10 barf bags we need
10 we we ran out because we have five
people in our family so we used all of
ours and then we returning to our
neighbors at like 3 in the morning you
like hey ex excuse me can I have your
back you know and then the next person
I'm sorry can we get this um sorry can
you can we have your back can we thank
you four we you need four more okay yeah
excuse you know it was oh y'all it was
it was tough I when I talked to this kid
would ask him hey can I tell the story
and they're like yeah but why do you
want to share I was like well I'm
talking about you know suffering and how
the mind did it he like you're suffering
this child's like you're what about me I
was suffering I was like okay well
that's fair but I suffered a little you
know and this is
um this is what I noticed the the hell
of it was mind you mean because on the
one hand you just had a situation to
deal with but that was the thing the
mind doesn't make it a situation it
tells stories and this is stuff going
through my head why is this happening to
me why couldn't it happened tomorrow
when we got home what are these people
thinking of us they hate us they hatte
everyone on this flight they hate us
please please get me off this flight get
me off no there's no Escape it's a
flight there is no hope I mean this is
just the you know the thought I'm just
kind of riding the roller coaster you
like okay they're getting better they're
getting better oh no here it comes again
you know I mean just riding the waves
like can you see how the soil of the
mind like it just
shapes reality to itself the way I might
sum it up is to say 99% of my suffering
is not what's happening to me but my
thoughts about what's happening to me
right in essence it's the story it's the
narrative it's the as Martin L said the
commenting chattering mind it's the it's
the Crazy Town you know I mean it's that
that mine that's what gets
us and and that's what
um turns the soil of our
heart
um well we could say just it poisons it
you know poisons the soil of the heart
so what do we do in those hellish
moments when the mind's attacking us
turning the soil of the heart into a
nuclear waste site it's in precisely
that moment when we don't argue with the
thoughts we don't uh we don't try to
shut them down stuff them you know but
we simply uh as Martin L says we just
breathe and we witness them we just
acknowledge them but here's the key
without believing
them without going with them and saying
yes I love that you know no no no no we
just witness them I think this is um one
of the p forms of prayer that I know
this is how we get out of the mind and
into the heart as theopen says and as we
do that we'll we'll notice a shift
happening ever so slowly a a Stillness
begins to descend upon us a quietness is
finding us God is changing the soil of
our
hearts in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we uh as we come to the table of
the Lord tonight as we take in the body
of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the wine may this be a moment
for you to just whisper a prayer you can
put it in your own words but maybe it
could be something like oh God change
the soil of my
heart help me help me enter into the
heart's
Stillness let me live from from that
place so um the way that we'll partake
tonight is we'll go row by row just
starting here from the front and kind of
working our way backwards we'll form uh
just one line right here in the middle
um you should know we practice um what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you'd like to
participate regardless of your
denomination or theological beliefs or
whatever if you want to connect with the
Risen Jesus then you're welcome to um
participate should also know that the
red is wine and the white is grape juice
so this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so
come you who have much
faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you who
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his
will should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
as we uh close out tonight I when I
found out we were going to do another uh
worship set I um requested this song
specifically um especially like as a
parting gift for all of you guys um for
all the ways um that you guys have
helped
me um even the people who have not been
here very long um and and the community
that has been found um in Jesus and
through Christ with with all the people
that I've met here um and there was a
time um about 8 months ago where I was
just going through the
motions um and no there was not a lot of
feeling and the the feelings that I were
getting
were the worst kind and I didn't feel
like there was anything left for me
and and I
really didn't know
um when like when it was going to be
over and I kept praying for it to end
and I didn't see any
hope and I remember sitting in service
one time and I heard the words of this
song and I just start sobbing because I
felt heard by God like I wasn't
screaming out into the void but like I
was being heard and listened to and
cared for and like this community is
what really got me through that point in
my life and specifically the words hold
on a little more this is not the end and
I remember feeling like it was the end
and God telling me no it's
not so
[Music]
bless it are the ones who do not
be oh the broken pieces of their
heart plac it are the tears of all the
weing
pouring like a sky of fallen
stars place it are the wounded ones in
morning brave enough to show the Lord
their
Skies place it all the hurts that are
not his
de open to the healing touch of
God the kingom is
yours the kingom is
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
him blessed are the ones who walk in
kindness even in the face of great abuse
blessed are the deed that go
unn serving with unguarded
gratitude blessed are the ones who fight
for
jce longing for the coming day of peace
blessed is the soul that thirst for
rightousness welcoming the last the lost
the
least the kingom is
[Music]
yours the kingom is
yours hold on little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
him the kingom is
yours the kingdom is
yours hold on a little oh this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on him
[Music]
blessed are the ones who suffer
vience and still have strength to love
their
enemies blessed is the faith of those
who
[Music]
per though they F they'll never know
defeat the kingom is
yours the kingdom is
yours hold on a little more this is not
the end
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him the kingom is
[Music]
yours the kingom is
yours hold on a little
more this is not the
end hope is in in the Lord keep your
eyes on
[Music]
him thank you praise
team I for one was very very very
blessed this evening by this wonderful
team in our
message thank you so much for joining us
this evening if this is your first time
or you are new um there is some
information a car well card that you can
fill out for your information we would
just like to say thank you answer any
questions and follow up
um you can also scan the QR code on the
screen but we would just really like to
say thank you if you are in need of a
prayer a
hug or any general support questions uh
find me right after the
service and we'd also if you get a
chance to hug our sweet dear friend
raymon who moved away and now he came
back to visit and we liked that surprise
this evening
so um so you can give him a
hug here at the table we are committed
to creating an
inclusive Christ centered community that
touches lives and generosity is a key
component in this Mission if you'd like
to join us in supporting this work
financially you can scan the QR code
on the screens um or you can go to the
on and also in the lobby or go to the
website at theable tx.org
all right now I would like to send you
out with the
benediction you can hold your hands in
prostrate to receive or posture to to
receive or just open your hearts to
these
words you are a child of of
God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day so as you go into this week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's holy spirit
in the desire to extend the same Gifts
of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact
with be
blessed have a good
week keep finding the good
soil and and we hope to see you back
next
week good night
[Music]